had seven kids living in Alabama
different baby daddies big as a house I
mean she had to be at least 150 pounds
overweight and I'm sorry ma'am that you
out of you're out of pocket and it's not
to put you down but someone has to tell
you the truth they don't have any male
figures in their life that are guiding
them so when they as they grow and
develop when they actually get attention
finally from a man it's only sexual how
did you get into manosphere content
Kevin Kevin Samuels so he really
downloaded to us his vision of what he
wanted and I sat here and I was like I
feel like I'm sitting here with Malcolm
X the same thing with me if I'm out of
pocket I need to be held accountable how
did you get into manosphere content
Kevin Kevin Samuel so I talked to Kevin
early on and he told me don't do it
really he said don't do it you're going
to be attacked
and I said I don't care you know I'll do
it I don't care because I felt as though
what he was saying to me it to me it was
so natural I was not understanding how
women didn't get it and I felt like
there needed to be more women to back
the men up in the space who truly
believe these things
um like I'm hearing my sister and my
cousin they are this way as well that
you know we're different people but my
sister she's like first time she heard
she was like where are the women
offended about like these women are
delusional so this is like women in my
family are this way so to me it was just
like this is it was like preschool it
felt like like temper tantrum children
that don't understand Basics and so I
said other women need to back him up
um and that was what my goal was what
was your relationship like with Kevin it
was Kevin to me was you know
I had so much respect for him like as a
like mentor
you know and I'll tell you
um myself and Dennis Berlin we were with
him on his last birthday
and he really downloaded to us his
vision of what he wanted and I sat here
and I was like I feel like I'm sitting
here with Malcolm X like we both were
saying it because he had a vision
um of how he wanted especially in the
black community and particularly with
all people but he said we were the most
in crisis especially in the U.S where
our families are broken down and a lot
of times it's going to start a lot of
the men are more ready to be husbands
and so he would just download knowledge
and he was just like a wealth of
knowledge and a lot of women thought he
hated women especially black women and
his entire goal was to be like a that
harsh father to wake them up because and
black women didn't like him because most
of us have not had fathers and we
certainly haven't had a male figure
that's an authority that cared about us
the mo the first interaction that most
black women have had with a man the man
has taken interest in them is sexual
from a from a young age not seeing being
touched some have but they don't have
any male figures in their life that are
guiding them so when they as they grow
and develop when they actually get
attention finally from a man it's only
sexual so this is how they develop where
it's that's why they they put the
sexuality out there so much and so this
was what Kevin was trying to teach you
haven't had a father really discipline
you my father was just like Kevin like
just like him so that's why I loved and
respected and appreciated him and that's
why I still stand ten toes for him and I
don't care who don't like it
cry on your corner okay that was like
the one person I wanted to meet like I
wanted to um I don't know I had two
sessions with him
um and he actually I um
I started my show in like February and I
talked to him in like December early
January
um and my whole goal when I started the
show was like I think because he told me
he might come to London in the spring
and I was like maybe if I get the show
big enough he could come on like and he
had no idea that now you didn't float
yeah yeah I know I know I know all right
yeah his
um I don't know I just loved his content
I thought it was excited it was great
and you know what was special about it
he was bringing on women and they were
telling on themselves we could see in
real time like he's not just talking
like just giving talking points women
are calling in he's responding to them
and a lot of people forget that a lot of
these women wanted high value men
there's one woman had seven kids living
in Alabama
different baby daddies big as a house I
mean she had to be at least 150 pounds
overweight and I'm sorry ma'am that you
out of you're out of pocket and it's not
to put you down but someone has to tell
you the truth so she he's told her to
rank herself because all the women had
to rank themselves first and he could
agree or disagree and they would be mad
at his opinion it because they want to
like you're not allowed to have an
opinion on what someone looks like so
she said with seven kids in Alabama 150
pounds overweight that she was a 10. and
that Kevin would be lucky to get with
her the these were the mindsets or some
women were less like that and they just
you could tell they were entitled and
thought they were just the ish they
thought you know a man needed to come up
to their level and or if they had a
high-powered job that that meant
something to a man no a broke man a man
that doesn't have anything he's that
concerned about your job but I know high
power men they'll marry a teacher if you
have a good mind you're smart they don't
they don't will they marry a woman who
has a good job but she also has to come
with humility and not use her job as a
way to
you know attract a man that does not
attract a man unless he's he's broken
wants to scam you and a hundred and then
they wonder why they're getting with
like they call them broken dust these
are guys that are using them or whatever
because you lead with your wallet as
well with your with your accomplishments
and that you're going to attract men who
are who want a woman that they can run
game on well and
150 pounds overweight oh my God how old
was she she because she he asked her her
height like she was like five two five
three but she had to be at least 300
pounds and even that I would say like
270 like a good 270 but at her height
she should have been below 130 140. at
5.2 and even that is still a lot of a
lot of questions how old was she do you
know she was in her 30s and I just don't
understand how in your 30s the world has
to have told you by the results in your
life it's trauma see a lot of them again
the first attention that a woman like
that will get was from men and so
they're looking for love so this is why
I don't try to be so harsh because I
understand people are raised in
environments to where they have to
survive
um or things happen to them as children
or so I understand that but we all have
trauma we all come from somewhere but
once you become an adult it is your
responsibility
um to take accountability for whatever
has happened in your life like a lot of
people don't know Kevin talked about on
Instagram you guys can look it up now
where he talked about he's gone to
therapy what's wrong with him he talks
about all of us have like a hurt all the
women have a hurt little girl inside of
them like there's a hurt little boy from
things and we have to give each other
Grace so they don't want to talk about
those things but a woman like that it
was funny because she was just so
delusional and she was really like nasty
about it too that's the other thing they
get nasty but then it's sad because it's
like this poor woman actually thinks she
actually believes this if she knows it's
not true but she has to do that in order
to feel good about herself because what
else could she do she I mean she's torn
her life to shreds with with where she
is do you see things getting better no
I don't either I was hoping I think it's
delusional I was hoping you would say
yes to be honest no no I live in reality
like a pro we live in rehab yeah that
was Kevin's vision and even I think most
we can hope for is 10 percent
um people who want better
and it's like trickle-down economics
when they see this group is getting
married this group is getting results
then people are going to be more curious
but we'll always have the you know it's
always going to be this mess yeah City
girl culture yeah City girl culture and
city boy culture you know but I do think
there's more men
that are way more traditional even City
boys that are way more traditional when
they come to looking for a wife they
will play in these streets when it comes
to a wife is tradition it's you know
they are much more ready to be husbands
there's way more husbands
than there are wives and I'm loving it
for the wives the women who are ready to
be wives
we we cleaning up well well and the
thing is a lot of times they'll say oh
you're harping on women you only talk
talk about the negatives about women but
I'm just like well how can we get better
if we don't admit there's a problem
because everything else caters to women
who else is telling women who is holding
women accountable in any space other
than YouTube other than what we do
everything there used to being pandered
to lied to Derek Jackson you know told
that you know uh you know a man who's 25
will get with a 60 year old with you
know a thousand kids like come on boy
stop playing on my phone
a woman
who hasn't had Authority or a man who
truly loves and cares about the results
of her life they just want to be
pandered and lied to because it feels
good it tickles the ear makes them feel
more than what they are and it feeds the
ego but like
it's not going to help you we have if
women don't talk to women who's going to
do it who's going to do it you know
who's going to teach you about how to
not get involved in entanglements and be
with f boys I don't deal with f boys you
do and I say that directly because I
learned how to
discern the right type of man because I
had men in my life who protected and
loved me how do you discern the right
type of man conversation
immediate conversation I'm not I don't
want to say it because then guys are
going to try to clean it up but I still
even if you try to fake it I'll cut
through the BS real fast
um because I know it's been modeled for
me so I know what a
how a man should come at you I know the
things he should say if he's coming
right off the if a man says you're
beautiful that's one thing but if it's
like I want to fly you out boy stop
playing on my phone fly me out okay
thanks next
um you know just on some goofiness I can
tell by the depth of his conversation
um is he honest is he willing to you
know I'll ask a guy provoking questions
and I'll see his response does he get
mad does he shy away from those subjects
does he lie I'll purposely ask things
that I know
the truth about and I want to see if he
likes so I can vet
you know
who this man his character what's a
provoking question that like you would
ask
um so let's say he hits me up on like I
know a lot of things about men right so
because of what I do so I see on his
Instagram he's taking a trip or a couple
trips to Colombia or Brazil
and I'll ask like as is like how do you
like Colombia or whatever oh yeah it was
great with my buddies and stuff and I
was like how you like the women there oh
it wasn't really I said really I said
the women that are so beautiful you
you my gosh
into taking nature and I'm like boy stop
playing on my phone next I I I'm not
saying that you absolutely did that but
let's let's be for real you know what
goes down even if you didn't partake if
I make a joke about it like oh those
women in Brazil did you meet a couple oh
no I'm you know I'm on a different path
and then like
it's just fake I know you're lying women
can smell simp it's like we could yeah
like and guys that just like tell you
what you want to hear you can just like
feel it I don't know right like tell me
the truth I respect you more if you keep
it a buck is what we say you know in the
U.S I don't know how much your audiences
you as person it's actually mostly you
out okay I was like it just happened I'm
a little up here I'm like keep it
up keep it keep it keep up like tell me
the truth that gives I respect a man
who's telling truth even if it hurts my
feelings or you think it's Gonna Hurt
it's very hard to hurt my feelings so
just give it to me straight so I can
respect I know you aren't a liar I know
I can trust whatever it is you you know
you're saying because you have no reason
to hide how did you find out that Kevin
died
oh gosh it was live streamed oh really I
was on a live stream earlier in the day
and somebody in there put that Kevin
just died and I was like okay this is a
troll kick him out and then a friend of
mine called me and was like I think it
may be true that Kevin died
and I said what how because they knew
someone who was in the police in Atlanta
and so they had but I they didn't tell
me that at the time they just said I had
some friends in Atlanta said they've
been hearing that as well
um and so I just went back on live
stream because I was started calling
Kevin's phones he had a couple phones I
started calling all his numbers I called
Dennis I call different people that knew
him and none of us could get a hold of
him
um and I kept calling he would always
pick up my calls and that was like a
really big red flag for me and and
especially on both or he would Texas say
let me hit you back and so I kept
calling and calling and calling nothing
and then
um so that's when I started to panic
because he was very consistent in his
communication with me because we were
working on a lot of different things and
um
and then finally I was we I started
calling hospitals live because so many
people said Melanie please stay live
with this because I wanted to see if
anyone had any information
um because I thought this was I thought
it was fake news so one of the things I
wanted to combat because people were
celebrating women were celebrating on
social media so if it was fake news I
wanted to in real time combat this
um and find out the truth and so and a
lot of people were scared and worried
like people who loved Kevin and so we
were all in there like trying to share
information then people were like call
Grady Memorial which is in Atlanta call
this Hospital call them county Morgue
call the police station because these
are things I didn't think of but we kind
of band together and then finally Dennis
called me
and he said and he gave me the details
he's like Kevin died he said we just got
the confirmation
so that was just
it was weird his birthday we were just
with him on his birthday I just talked
to him like two days before it was just
a lot it was even now that's why I
couldn't go to his funeral
it just shocked me so bad I
I like I can go to family members
funerals things like that but like
friends I have a very difficult time
especially because I saw him changing
the world and I felt like I lost like a
black leader like Malcolm X or Martin
Luther King not to that level but in
terms of helping the black family
um and to this day I I couldn't even
watch the memorial and things they did
because it's just even now I felt like
the world lost a king
and so for me it wasn't just personal it
was it was devastating it was
devastating it still is so what projects
were you guys working on
his tour we were putting together
conferences
um he's about to do a tour
um we were working because Kevin had no
one actually directly helping him with
anything he was doing it all so he was
getting behind on everything was hard so
we're working on how can I
a system and help him manage the emails
the things get you know getting all that
kind of back in in order to help him
um somebody that he can trust you know
he had to be you know because he a lot
of people came at him but it had to be
he knew he knew I knew YouTube I had
been doing YouTube longer than him not
in this space
um he liked the fact that I had more
success than he had on YouTube in my
former life and so he knew I knew the
business so we were working on he wanted
me to help run that back in and then
also getting him geared up to do we were
planning like a multi-city conference
tour and then he had like TV bookings he
was doing he had a book he wasn't
working on the book with me but you know
so it was like those types of things
because he didn't trust he didn't trust
at all a lot of people do you feel like
anyone really carried the torch after
him I feel like yes I feel like you have
I feel like you know in TR I feel like
everyone in this space you know to
degree has carried the torch like in
their own lane mm-hmm do I think there
will ever be another Kevin no I think
there's imitations but they it's just
it's just not the same it's the Walmart
version yeah you know and
see Kevin a lot of people are just
jumping on this bandwagon Kevin was
talking about this
even in like high school college he's
been this man since early on so and and
you know he was in his 50s so a lot of
people are younger they're just jumping
on it because it makes money or it looks
easy to do it looks lucrative or they
believe in it now but they haven't like
really dived into the books the
teachings and having that Charisma that
level of sophistication as well I have
not seen anyone have where he was a
total package in terms of bettering
yourself you know being straight up
honest the way he presented in his suits
high-end things like like you know just
moving into being a high value man but
also women seeing you know what a high
value man looks like
especially in our community you know
like they think wearing a Gucci
sweatsuit means you're high-end
no that's not how people with real money
actually move in this world so it
someone who lived that life could teach
that I don't see anyone else that can do
that right now well and you could tell
how much work he did behind the scenes
with I mean I don't I don't even know
this for sure it just seemed like he did
a lot of one-on-ones behind the scenes
because you could just tell the way he
would dissect someone I've sort of
noticed it the more I do shows like you
can kind of start to make
there's like the same stories and
different people that you start to hear
over and over again and you can only get
that good by talking to like hundreds of
thousands of people and you can just
tell he's done it yeah and he's been
doing it for decades yeah you could you
can tell yeah so like um and you can't
fake that and you can't teach it even
his old College buddy um uh what is it
is it TDA Randolph she went to college
with him and she's about this is how
Kevin was in college he used to hold
like round tables with men and women
back then it takes you have to be
seasoned to get to that level of wisdom
and perception in those things so
um and I think I'm not saying other
people can't get there or they aren't
moving in that direction uh but it's you
know everyone has their own lane there's
only be one there will be one Pearl
there'll only be one of everybody so I
don't think anyone should fulfill his
shoes they should step into their own
lane and and and we'll see you know what
projects of his would you like to see
continued the tour the tour I think I
think we need we're all all online I
think I think
um I think a lot of people want to meet
the people in this space connect meet
Network and meet other people not just
online but you know
having one-on-one connection with not
only the YouTubers but I think the
um each other you know and
because it's very fragmented you can do
collabs with people you can kind of talk
in the comments or meet on Instagram do
meetups and things but I think it needs
to be taken to the next level to be
taken seriously like I feel like this is
a whole movement and it needs to elevate
to the next level and and not just be
YouTubers and that and that's what his
vision was he wanted an entire network a
whole television show I worked in
televisions like we were like it was
like a proof it was like these these
Progressive steps that we wanted to take
so
what would happen on the tour like what
because I I know we talked about it
briefly so it's like public speaking or
what what goes on in the tour so there's
two different versions of it so there
can be a tour which is like a one day
some people just like a like an evening
tour where you come together as a panel
live and people buy tickets just say you
know maybe you have like like an after
party
um that people can get tickets to so
that's one way to do a tour you just do
like a live panels for a couple hours
and different people come out and talk
people can ask questions live then they
can do me you do meet and greets with
the people like you know fans or people
who watch you the other one is actually
do conferences so that's a whole
different ball game it's more involved
but I do think it adds more value so
where you actually have just like a
normal conference you have different
speakers throughout the day breakout
sessions to deal with different sectors
of things keynote speakers different
events and then yeah um you know in the
conference with a you know like I I
definitely think it should be something
that's more black tie like a high-end
kind of oh that would be so fun right
and everyone get all dressed dressed up
after the conference and then the next
day where we call I'm like giving out
the bag right here guys sorry I can't
give up the wrong bag probably girl no
one's gonna do it I know it's like you
can you can give people a golden idea no
one will do it like and then the next
date like you could sell separate
tickets for a VIP brunch like with those
YouTube like the people so and it was a
limited number you can also do
one-on-one sessions uh with people can
separate ticket I know all these things
because my sister ran events for the NFL
and uh David Nagel I don't know if
you've seen him people would pay ten
thousand to a hundred thousand to come
into His events wow so she's like Tony
Robbins type of guy so and she even
bought a travel agency just to like help
like like coordinate so I know this
world and how to do it because this is
like her entire life this is all she's
done so that's why I'm more in and I I
know how much money is in it and I know
the level it takes you to when you're
not just like online it's another level
of respect that you will get out there
um in the mainstream you have a very
successful family you guys are all doing
I'm like wow I have a successful Family
Guy yeah let's not talk okay no but
thank you it takes one to know more
right
uh wait tell me a little bit about your
YouTube career before I just started
doing
um kids content
um I had a vision of wanting to do it uh
it was when kids content first started
taking off they started doing egg
surprise
where these people this lady who used to
be um Disney uh with her she was
something is that like kids blogs or
kids like kids Vlogs didn't exist okay
when I started it was egg surprise and
toy surprise so they would get these
Easter eggs and they were just like hey
guys today someone like for toddlers and
some for older kids but my daughter was
two my youngest was two and she'd be
mesmerized by this lady with this baby
voice that would just open Easter eggs
today we have a PAW Patrol Easter egg
they went we have 30 surprise eggs and
she would just like be transfixed and
I'm like what the people do toy unboxing
and so and then I found Ryan's toy
review who was the biggest YouTuber in
the world and so they were doing like
nursery rhyme songs he'd just be going
to the park he would just be you know
running around the house and with a song
on and it was getting millions of views
and then I read an article so I was just
like okay this is Goofy but okay
um at least it keeps them busy while I'm
trying to cook or whatever and then I I
did I it just it just fascinated me and
I wanted to make sure it wasn't going to
be someone that jumped out you know
flashed the kids or something crazy so I
looked up her name I can't think of her
name right now
um but and I looked it up and it was an
article in line about what people were
making on YouTube all of the top
YouTubers that year were in the kids
space she was one of them and she had
made six million dollars that year I
said
I said man I thought this was a hobby a
fun you made six million dollars opening
these ghetto Easter eggs that I can go
to Dollar Tree and get are you under I
said there is no way so I started doing
my research and
um
I was like well
I can do this and at the time I said
there was no kids that looked like my
daughters there were no
um there were like Asian kids there were
some white kids they weren't really
black kids and so I said you know what
um and I didn't do it just for that I'm
not so big into race but I do think it
does speak it is encouraging
um you know especially for young black
children to see
modeling or examples or see themselves
and things it's not the end-all be-all
but I said you know what I feel like we
could do this so I started doing it but
similar to other people were I didn't
get the same views I got no views and so
then I started going into the world of
kids and I just discovered like skits
plant and so I just started doing void
one day I just said you know what let's
just do a pretend play with Elsa and
Anna dolls I would do with my children
anyway I would do it with them anyway we
would do pretend play I said is it like
puppets no no just the doll from the
store like a like a 18 inch Elsa doll
and Anna doll from Frozen because Frozen
was huge at the time so you would go to
the store you'd buy the dolls and then
you know we already have the dolls
because I would already do like tea
party I decided let me play with the
kids online the way I play with my kids
in real life create stories and voices
like I don't know Anna I want to go
there that's not fair Elsa you know it's
just like I'm the little sister I should
I want to take a book or I would come up
with scenarios that like one of my
daughters uh dropped her toothbrush in
the toilet and then the other one told
her it was going to turn into a snake
and so I just turned that into like I'm
scared I can't
I can't and so I just did that and this
is so cool a different voice I'm sorry
guys I was surprised I have altars
there's several personalities
so but then I would just I said let me
play with these children because a lot
of kids their parents aren't playing
with them they don't have time this is
no dis on parents but I was a
stay-at-home mom doing homeschooling so
I had the time and energy
and I just did that and it just went
from zero to 100 million views in one
month wow so it was like like on that
level you're getting a hundred million
200 million I know people are getting a
billion views a month on YouTube do you
in that space do you still do that at
all I don't do it my girl said
divorce shut it down had to regroup
um and my daughters are older but I I I
I have some I have some thoughts I have
some thoughts coming in my mind and
we'll see what we do is it still on
YouTube the channel yeah what's it
called I
and I never showed my face for the first
three years but it's an awesome world to
be in when we were in it but I I don't
think the kids space is not the same uh
the money you would make is not the same
it's not as much or what oh it's not as
much like this was the one this was the
Wild Wild West back then
um it was fun but there's been a lot of
what they call kidpocalypse
um Kappa got involved you know the
government it's uh the child's online
privacy and protection act
whoo okay it's a whole different ball
game so I don't recommend people going
into kids content unless you're going to
do do it well like cocoa melon you ever
heard of that okay so they're like the
biggest probably preschool brand in the
world but they were a family just on
YouTube doing videos they were tired
like what it was and so he decided to
just get some songs made hired like some
people from India to do animation and
now it's a multi-billion dollar brand
so like this is people that move in that
space I know people who do 50 million
dollars a month in toys and products
from in Walmart so it's a whole
different ball 40 million
three months that is insane yes so it's
a different world and I enjoyed it and
more than anything I I like kids content
I like working I like working with kids
I enjoy family and I actually saw my
children building Legacy for my children
you know and for my family and my goal
is always told my girls I wanted them to
have enough money that they can do what
they want in terms of change in the
world they want to build schools in
Africa they want to you know whatever
they want to do the money does not
withhold them from where their true
heart lies so
how did that space compare to the
manosphere space was Kevin right yes yes
I it was much more PL I mean you have
your drama there but people don't attack
you it's not so emotional people aren't
like so opinionated it's just you're
Freer you can be creative
there's no judgment
um it's just it's funny I mean it's hard
work I'm not gonna lie it's hard work
but it's to me it's just I mean you're
working with kids you're not having to
deal with adults in their temper
tantrums and their feelings and and
everyone has an opinion and I'm just
like if you know so much then come do
this boo like like step it up like you
have a lot of you know uh you know
people on the sidelines that want to
come in or people want to destroy you
because they have no Talent they have
nothing to say so they need you they
need to destroy someone else in order to
have any views or have anything we're
dealing with a lot of narcissists just
so you guys know we're dealing with
Psychopaths sociopaths and narcissists
people who dedicate channels just to
diss other people and videos
sorry I'm talking fast sorry guys
um it's been shown like they're
narcissists I can even hear the
psychopathy in these people I mean just
to be that nasty and negative so you're
not sure there's narcissists of people
over there but they're not attacking
and being so emotional I'm like grow up
like if you don't like it move on kick
rocks like peace out that's that's been
the hardest part for me of getting on
the Internet Was it's just how much they
attack you like within your space it's
weird yeah and it's men yeah for me it's
been men I have not been attacked by
women like that no all the women are
trying so good job you know the women
are way like they're just chill it's
like men and I just say like come out
your feminine dude you need to attack if
a man has to attack women in order for
them to get views
wait what does that say about you and
not in women who are on your side as a
man we're not talking about you know
women running around scamming men we're
talking about people on your side but
that shows their innate like I want to
say it's feminine nature but it shows a
lot of these people have mental
undiagnosed or diagnosed mental health
issues so I choose not to engage with
you know people like that because you're
low value if that's what you have to do
for review it's just you're and you
don't even really get views so that's
what's sad about it like you really
think you hate but okay boo you hate
like no Crumbs are left you you you hurt
us over here you did it so kids you
might go back into the kids stuff though
different sector of YouTube like what's
your what's your plan moving forward
first of all I want to be a wife my
marriage didn't work out for different
reasons when I didn't go into that but I
enjoy being a wife
um that's actually my priority is to
um have my husband find me who I'm
supposed to be with I enjoy that I like
I said I grew up wanting to be a
stay-at-home wife
so all of this other stuff is just
because I enjoy doing it but I say my my
goal
um like right now is to be Diversified
on YouTube which I am like I have
channels people don't know about
um you know where I call YouTube
automation things where
eventually I may even disappear from the
internet for a while just because I'm
making enough money or you know I don't
know how my husband will feel about
things and so that's my number one goal
is to for that but also I want to help
people find relationships I want that is
something I truly want to help
um and the day I stop helping the day I
feel like there's not enough value in
what I'm doing anymore I'm not going to
do it if I feel like I'm causing more
harm or I'm not getting the results
people aren't really changing and
growing I'm not going to beat my head
against the wall just for this
so so maybe matchmaking in your future
that I'm actually I well many ladies
watching that I actually have a lot of
high value men who come to me to want me
to vet women for them or help match
Majors like well who are your friends do
you know women so that's something I
would like to do is which I need to have
like a course
um to show women not these femininity
courses like femininity is is what you
were born with you just the world has
made you and nurture has made you
masculine
so that's getting you back to your your
set point but then what are the duties
of a wife what are men looking for so
you are attracting the man the highest
quality man that you can so that's what
I would like to do is is which you've
done with the wife School having been
raised as a wife having been a wife I
know
I know the like the details the the the
layers of this that that is required so
that if I could do that that would be
and do the matchmaking I figured women
are going to want it because especially
if they see some of my high-end clients
they're just like oh my gosh him I want
to sign up for this you know um and a
lot of guys are just like here's the
work you have to do they're like right
never mind right right they don't want
to do it they don't want to do it I mean
what a lot of women will be motivated if
the men look good enough they have
enough money and they're the men that
these women want women will start to
change a lot of the women are called
into Kevin's show you should see he
showed me to back in a lot of y'all
wanted to get with him come on there
barking and saying all that you know
they want a lot I don't want to get with
him I heard him say that on a show a lot
like this one girl slid in his D I
remember him showing it on the show
several of them he actually had some
celebrity clients which I'll never tell
about but like yeah people would be
shocked at you know and what was going
on with this a lot of these women who
were even mad at him they were her hurt
that he didn't consider him them a 10 or
not a nine or ten and they went on there
because they wanted high value men to
see them and they were embarrassed that
he didn't rank them high enough and
that's why they would get mad and have
this kind of sense of false bravado so
women are motivated by the men they want
that that's the only thing I see that
makes them want to change
tell me about your struggles with mental
health I know I saw your video a couple
months back as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible